family and individual open enrollment
period it's happening now through
january 15th and select health who is
sponsoring this segment will be hosting
a phone bank tomorrow here to give us a
preview is sebastian and greg from the
select health answer team welcome guys
good day how are you doing good to see
you guys what is the number one question
you get asked about open enrollment boy
it has to be deadlines deadlines and and
the process what is needed for the
process and here in nevada january 15th
is our deadline to have an effective
date of february first so need to know
that and the ways you can do that is by
asking questions to us tomorrow we'll be
happy to answer those questions you have
selecthealth.org and you have the nevada
health link that can help you get the
the services that you need for your
health insurance enrollment services
workflow we're at the phone bank and
both you gentlemen other staff members
will be back there and anyone has any
kind of questions they can call and
you'll answer them
that's perfect we're the answer team
that's right that's right answer team so
let's talk about more i was reading that
you guys have tax credits tell us more
about the tax credits
absolutely one of the things that a lot
of families maybe didn't qualify for
before so we want them to remember that
they may qualify for 2022 is a subsidy
so help to pay for the premium for the
health insurance and a lot of families
also may qualify for a reduction on
their co-pays deductibles and
co-insurance so there's a lot of help
out there to help subsidize you know the
cost of health care and a lot of
families again that maybe in the past
had a small subsidy or no subsidy may
qualify now for one so we want everybody
to give it a chance and go to
our website give us a call or listen to
to our you know presentation tomorrow
now also i was reading to you guys do a
lot when it comes to gym memberships
it's all about health we want to promote
health and in good health in 2022 what
are some of the discounts and stuff that
you guys offer well there's there's
there's several and if you're an
individual and you you become a member
for 240 it can be put towards a gym
membership that's great and if you're a
family it'd be 580
and if if there's certain certain plans
that we have if you've taken 7 000 steps
a day we can also help you out that way
everyone's looking right now checking
their phone to see how many steps they
did today i don't think i'm at the 7000
mark that is great something else too uh
share reductions what are share
reductions well that's exactly you know
uh what a lot of people have in mind
which is when you purchase a health plan
is i have a deductible that i have to
cover before the insurance will kick in
i have a 20 or 30 percent of the cost
once you once i use medical services so
the share reduction means that a lot of
families may qualify to reviews that
co-pay to zero that deductible maybe to
zero and that thirty or twenty percent
to a lower co insurance so that will
help you with your cost when you use
your medical services and this phone
bank tomorrow it's great someone's
watching right now married single they
got a family they have some questions
you guys are gonna have the answers and
you'll spend time with them too it's not
a quick answer someone has a bunch of
questions you'll answer all of them
let's let's take care of all your
questions uh the deadline is the 15th
we're here to help everyone out uh we
have a facebook live also happening too
so we want to be available and we want
to make all those questions uh become
reality so you can be insured i love it
gentlemen thank you so much tomorrow is
go time for you guys we'll see you back
here at the station we appreciate it
thank you you can call the eight uh
channel light phone bank with live
select health answer team tomorrow from
three to seven
uh select health are the sponsors of
this segment and they're located at 1960
festival plaza suite 930. for more
information go to
selecthealth.org in las vegas now we'll
be right back